to 192 david p is the voicemail number
for the show this is a number you can
call any time of day if it's 355 a.m. in
the morning and it's one minute after
donald trump has tweeted something crazy
and you want to call us you can call at
3:55 a.m. in the morning good because
there's always someone I want to speak
to at that time and it's called the
voicemail number that's good enough for
many Trump can't call Michael Flynn
anymore to ask him questions about
currency like he used to do in the
middle of the night so everybody needs
an outlet everybody needs someone to
talk to you okay
here is one idea from a viewer about
something that Democrats should run on
for 2018 and 2020
hi David I just wanted to say one of the
greatest pallette forms that the
Democratic Party could do is in 2020
campaign and 2018 campaign the
presidential nominee needs to explain
who the US Attorney General is going to
be and how we're going to go after the
bankers bad Republican politicians like
Governor Chris Christie and the
lobbyists and how we're just going to
put all of these bad actors away okay
interesting idea right running a
campaign on we're really going to clean
it up here's who I'm thinking about for
my attorney general here is what they
will be working on here are the people
we will be looking into and you can
include corrupt politicians you can
include lobbyists you can include
banksters it actually is way more of a
law-and-order approach then the
law-and-order approach that Trump self
promoted during the campaign certainly
would be unprecedented to to name your
Attorney General before even winning the
election yeah and I think it's great to
you know go after the lobbyists and the
bankers but saying that you're going to
go after Republican politicians that can
sound a little authoritarian but hey
Trump did it you will lock her up and he
did but maybe you say I will go after
every politician regardless of party
that has been involved in the in the
illegal corruption or whatever like you
could figure out a way to do it and
maybe you say I will appoint an attorney
general who will do these things without
saying exactly who very interesting idea
I think what we're increasingly all
agreeing on is this better deal run to
the middle approach that we're seeing
with Kamala Harris and all this other
stuff that's not the right approach for
Kratts we've got a great bonus show for
you today new study says moderate
drinking might improve your memory
a man has rescued a massive teacher a
sea turtle not a tea turtle a sea turtle
stuck on its back in Mexico and NASA
will be chasing next month's solar
eclipse with two jet planes where will
Pat be on the day of that eclipse we
will find out those stories and more on
today's bonus show sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership get instant
access and we'll speak to you then